to me know what's most exciting about
our universe and also philosophically
and emotionally and spiritually most
empowering and interesting about it is
that through us a universe has actually
become aware of its or of itself yeah
for the first part of the 13.8 billion
years since a Big Bang there was no one
home our universe is doing all this cool
stuff it's actually no one home well in
the earliest moments right after a big
bang when it was just a plasma expanding
plasma blow him you know much harder
than the core of the Sun I'm pretty sure
there was no consciousness in there the
life could be around as early as just a
couple billion years ago in other ways
earlier than that yes it's quite
possible but but very early on and I
think it's very likely that it was just
their way to in this hospitable for any
kind of consciousness and then gradually
it went from being very simple and
boring and to being grabbed more and
more complex and the first self-aware
entities appeared yeah that's in a sense
of universal waking up and becoming
aware of itself right we know what
happened here yeah on this planet maybe
it's happened elsewhere yeah maybe not
yet we can come back to that towards
complexity mm-hmm yes
in any case I think that's the most
important thing that it's happened so
far because if you look at all these
laws of physics they don't say anything
about beauty meaning or purpose mm-hmm
yeah look beauty meaning and purpose are
all things which you know which old it
only exists when there is experience
because those are are in some sense
experiences right you can only have
suffering or joy or pleasure which are
experiences when there is experience way
so if we go extinct and all life and our
universe goes extinct to get the story
by a deaf bubble or some dumb
technological mishap we build our you
know if we go back to being meaningless
and before I woke up it was all so
meaningless in the sense
this is a very literal sense there was
no meaning because meaning is a kind of
something you experience so this is I
think the most beautiful thing that's
happened so far this blob get this this
universe gradually got so complex that
it woke up and well yeah and what we one
of the most striking things I think
we've learned through science is that
not only has the universe woken up now
but it has the potential to wake up much
more yes and as yet you know yes I was
taking a little power nap before this
interview and when I first woke up I
just woke up like a little bit and then
became more and more conscious right you
went through this same procedure this
morning I feel like universe is like
that too we are having very interesting
experiences we humans but it's clear you
know which can wake up more you look
around on the telescope yes and it's
clear that the vast majority of space
it's not as alive as it could be some
people who listen to this maybe think we
live in are convinced we live in a Star
Trek kind of cosmos where there is all
of those cool things going on all over
the place and they're just hiding from
us there's not any really cyclic
evidence for it yet you know maybe there
is other life and really really far away
the zoo hypothesis there's an
interesting ones yeah but I think it's
much more likely that our universe has
much more potential in the future and I
think one of the most inspiring things
for me personally to think about is what
can I do to help our universe wake up
more more yes imagine from if it turned
out that you know we discovered that the
only life on all of Earth you know was
in Rhode Island or you know there was
nothing outside a Rhode Island no plants
no animals no nothing we might even feel
then that we have a moral responsibility
help life spread to help the rest of the
planet so it can wake up more so they
can be more joy more joy
interesting and and and weary instances
across all different styles of
experience exactly yeah the opposite
thing we could do is more ideas more
creativity yes yeah exactly and the
opposite thing we could do is set off
some gigantic hydrogen bomb explosions
and kill that all life and Rhode Island
- doctor we feel like you kind of bad
idea which is a lot of what you do with
existential risk mitigation so fun but
but if you get if that's bad then
clearly the opposite is a good thing to
help life spread red yes and if you look
out into the cosmos that's exactly what
it is except much more extreme and going
from Rhode Island to Earth going from
Earth to help life spread throughout our
Milky Way galaxy and the hundreds of
billions of other galaxies it's a good
analogy would be a dream would be
dramatically more positive I think then
yes it's just going from Rhode Island to
Earth yes and I think most people lose
sight of just how much opportunity there
is for the future